alors déjà avant toute chose je vais
vous sachez que mon but c'était pas ni
d'être le porte parole d'une dette une
lanceuse d'alert bien que finalement je
pense que c'est une bonne chose
je suis
en fait ça fait longtemps que moi je
suis au courant de cette histoire
que j'ai vu cette vidéo alors est ce que
sont bien sûr son sens à notre âge parce
que c'est vrai que la vidéo est très
grave est ce que vous pouvez expliquer à
douter les spectateurs ce qu'on voit
dans cette vidéo bien sûr on voit une
jeune fille c'est une pièce qui est tout
noir
enfin on peut-être un peu éclairé mais
sombre la personne film avec le flash
une personne qui filme il ya deux
personnes donc une personne qui filme la
personne qui est acteur de la vidéo il
ya une jeune fille donc assise sur un
bord de lit ou je sais pas trop enfin
sur un truc soutient ali et la personne
en question s'avance vers elle n'a pas
de pantalon un tee shirt bien tee shirt
blanc donc j'espère que cette vidéo sera
retrouvé et c'est très drôle visiblement
on attrape la jeune fille par les
cheveux elle veut pas dit non on essaye
de lui demander des faveurs et elle
refuse elle pleure moi j'ai vu une
personne en fait la vidéo très ému quand
vous racontez 2 en fait si vous la
connaissiez pas en plus est cette jeune
fille mais
en fait je peux pas je connais pas la
personne mais quand je vois un truc
comme ça c'est même pas tant la vidéo
qui m'a choqué c'est les suit en fait
c'est la vidéo en elle même les je pense
que n'importe qui vous vous tous vous
voyez cette vidéo vous ne pouvez pas
rester la jeune fille pleure elle hurle
et a dû son aile dure une minute trente
elle pleure elle supplie elle dit je
t'en supplie arrête non moi je suis
désolé mais non ça veut dire non donc au
bout de quelques instants car la
personne sur cette vidéo
jette la jeune fille comme ça et lui
dire elle n'était pas drôle il va les
voir ta copine sachant que tout le long
elle rigole regarde la caméra assez
marrant et tout juste alix la question
que doivent se poser de téléspectateurs
qui se pose certainement les
chroniqueurs commencer cette vidéo
circule en fait alors moi je vais vous
expliquer dans quel cadre on l'a montré
parce qu'ils trouvent que c'est une
personne publique
moi qui me l'a montré dans une
conférence de presse je vais vous dire à
quelle conférence de presse c'était la
conférence de presse après les
marseillais contre le résume honda faro
d'accord voilà nous étions sur le
rooftop
des terrasses du port à marseille je
sortais d'une interview et il se trouve
que la personne qui m'a montré cette
vidéo je l'avais averti quant à la en
tout cas de ce que je pense moi de base
à
la négativité de la personne avec qui
ils étaient a continué tout le temps
quand c'est à dire que c'est à dire que
c'est un avis personnel c'est c'est un
ami de la personne qui était sur le
circuit chemise vous d'accord voilà c
est donc vous c'est lui qui vous a
montré cette vidéo mais en fait il vous
montre cette vidéo à l'excès quoi ils
sont ventilés regarde c'est rôles en
fait il s'est passé une chose c'est que
moi comme je l'avais promis à plusieurs
reprises que ce n'était pas quelqu'un
avec qu'il fallait travailler parce que
tôt ou tard ça allait mal se passer
quand si c'est avéré qu'ils ont eu des
soucis il a voulu venir me dire regarde
tu avais raison parce que moi je ne
parlais plus à cause de ça parce que moi
je suis tu parle à des gens que j'aime
pas il est en possession de vidéos et il
vient me la montrer pour me dire que tu
avais raison c'est une merde je dis oui
c'est bien elle m'a dit oui mais regarde
ce qu'il a fait est là on m'a cherché la
vidéo et pendant que je regardais
horrifié ja une personne qui jacassent
et dans mon oreille me dire ah mais tu
te rends compte en plus la fia avait 16
ans puisqu'elle n'a pas sa carte
d'identité plaqué sur le front et j'ai
pas inventé en détails sordides parce
que je pense que c'est assez sale comme
ça
le fêtait ses que la seule réaction que
j'ai eu à ce moment là c'est qu'en fait
j'ai tout de suite incriminer la
personne qui va montrer la vidéo donc
c'est à dire moi je pars du principe que
si tu montes une vidéo de ce genre bas
et que en plus de ça
tu n'as pas fait en sorte de la rendre
publique sachant que les personnes en
question à ce moment là c'était on se
tirer dessus à couteau
est-ce que ce que quelqu'un qui a essayé
de contacter cette jeune fille alors le
problème c'est que la jeune fille en
question je n'ai aucune idée de qui ça
peut être d'accord personne et utile à
je savais alors la retrouver j'ai écouté
et je la seule chose que je fais
aujourd'hui et croyez moi c'est pas
facile parce que je n'avais pas envie de
prendre cette position et je me rends
compte qu'en fait on est beaucoup à être
au courant et que l'on on est tous des
lâches en fait on s'était tous donc
c'est très bien mais je pense que
maintenant que j'ai ouvert la boîte de
pandore faut aller jusqu'au bout
moi je veux qu'il y ait une enquête
policière parce que je mens pas je
prendrais pas le risque en plus je suis
en train de tout faire pour m'éloigner
de ce milieu là je prendrai pas le
risque de dire des choses aussi graves
parce que je vous dit alix il ya moi je
vous dit tout il ya plein de gens qui
vont dire aussi je me fais l'avocat du
diable également qu'ils vont dire oui
mais comme alix ne veut plus faire ça
elle crache dans la soupe et elle est
absolument voter les histoires doc c'est
vous c'est pas le but moi je crache pas
dans la soupe de ce que j'ai vu je suis
j'ai enfin généreusement je pense que
reconnaissance de ce que j'ai eu en
revanche ce n'est pas parce qu'on reçoit
des choses qu'il n'y a pas forcément des
problèmes dans le système c'est un
problème que je viens d'énoncer là parce
que c'est pas un cas isolé d'accord en
fait hawx est en fait vous parce que
j'ai voulu avec ses seulement on vous a
senti très ému quand vous parliez de la
vidéo tout à l'heure où vous a senti
très choqué vous en faites vous vous
êtes senti pas investi d'une mission
vous êtes dit il faut que je parle mais
il faut plus que ça arrivait qu on
arrête on arrête tout ça dans dans ce
milieu de la télé réalité c'est ça moi
je vais vous expliquer comment ça s'est
passé parce qu'il faut être vraiment
honnête
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai incriminé la
personne directement lui demandant
pourquoi vous avez 7 juin de la personne
qui était sur la vidéo on dit que c'est
évidemment la bière seine qui m'a montré
d'accord moi je suis personnellement je
n'ai nominés personnes d'accord je ne le
ferai pas je le ferais auprès de la
police et si je suis là pour ça aussi
parce que j'espère que la ou les
personnes qui auraient pu être victimes
de genre de chose de cette personne
d'autres personnes prennent conscience
que c'est pas parce qu'on est connue
qu'on ait une pastille bleue sur
instagram de tout est permis et qu'il
faut qu'ils comprennent que dans ce
milieu là aussi à des femmes et que
c'est pas parce que tu t'es retrouvé
dans une situation peut-être parce que
tu as vu des gens connus tu as voulu
passer une soirée avec des retards et
cas prête à changer d'avis peu importe
la raison il ne faut pas se sentir
honteuse moi j'ai parlé avec d'autres
personnes qui ont eu à faire même genre
de soucis même genre de personnes vers
je viens pas faire la police je viens
juste dire aux personnes qui ont été
victimes que si jamais elles ont besoin
de quelqu'un qui les soutiennent et qui
a qui a été témoin parce qu'en fait j'ai
vu si l'avant entre mes mains cette
vidéo je serai pas là en fait ça on
serait devant les tribunaux de france
vous avez essayé d'alerter quelqu'un oui
j'ai alerté plusieurs productions donc
toutes les productions des princes de
l'amour toutes les productions avec des
contacts à ce moment là jugé averti des
personnes très haut placées dans toutes
les productions qu'est ce que vous a dit
j'ai une des productions qui m'a répondu
que
[Musique]
ouais c'est là que c'est très grave en
fait c'est que
ça un milieu de la chance fait tous des
lâches clairement et les productions
protègent certaines choses alors je sais
pas pourquoi
moi quand j'ai expliqué à une personne
très haut placées d'une production ce
que je venais de voir quelques semaines
avant parce que je me suis retrouvé un
endroit où je savais que ça allait être
compliqué et je les fais en interne
parce que j'ai pas la vidéo je peux pas
aller porter plainte on m'a dit alors je
suis pas au courant de cette vidéo par
contre je sais qu'il ya eu des problèmes
avec d'autres personnes d'ailleurs on a
une personne qui ne souhaite pas venir à
cause d'eux ensuite on m'a dit
d'ailleurs les nounous ont été avertis
que ça peut être dangereux donc ils ont
une information qui fait qu' il faut
qu'ils soient un petit peu plus présents
elie gilles ans pour pas que cette
personne se retrouve seul avec des
jeunes filles
moi j'entends ça ça veut dire que je
vais bien la présomption d'innocence et
que la personne soupçonnée il sera dans
les principaux ses deux amours à partir
du plasma de ce qui l'attend mais moi je
n'ai jamais dit ça ça c'est ce que vous
avez dans mais moi je veux c'est lui
même qui a dit que c'était lui il est
régulier qui a été aussi sa de ce jeune
homme a envie de ce fait dénoncer
et de dire qu'on parle de lui le fasse
chez moi j'ai nommé comme moi je ne
dénonce personnes jeunes et nominé
personne parce que la seule personne les
seules personnes à qui nos minerais les
personnes des situations ce sera face
aux institutions qui peuvent faire
quelque chose aujourd'hui je peux
difficilement le faire parce que je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
étouffés d'ailleurs je suis pas la seule
à pouvoir vous dire ce genre de choses
je pense et c'est surtout que je veux
que si jamais ces victimes allemand
elles comprennent il ya personne qui est
au dessus des lois et on est là aussi et
moi je veux qu'elle comprenne ça donc
c'est pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour accuser qui que ce soit
c'est juste pour dire que s'il ya des
victimes faut pas qu'elles qu'elles
restent dans le silence et qu'elle se
faut qu'elles se sont accompagnées parce
que c'était plus une autre